the most difficult we have today is our
attention gets hijacked there is so much
happening in our lives that we pay
attention to and and quite frankly you
know the little devices that we carry
around don't help very much because our
attention gets totally absorbed into
that attraction from these little
devices and we get a little bit of
dopamine all the time when we get all
information information is valuable
instinctively so we want to know what's
happening and what's going on it's true
for gossip and that's true for why we
watch the news but the problem is that
our attention is so much absorbed in
that that we rarely if ever pay
attention to just being present and that
is really what mindfulness and
meditation is trying to balance out a
little bit so that when the mind quiets
and you actually are at home in your
body that that that distraction fades
away and you actually get in touch with
that underlying happiness that the
Greeks call eudaimonia I think to begin
with it would be really valuable to
become aware of attention and how it
automatically shifts from one to the
other and it can happen in lightening
speed when if suddenly there would be a
huge loud noise we would all try one
what is it and on our attention is
immediately hijacked an attention at its
core was also a very important
evolutionary adaptation because what
happens with attention is it either goes
to the highest opportunity or goes to a
highest threat that we perceive in our
environment so suddenly there is
something that we you know an
hunter-gather time something that was
available to eat and then that's where
our attention goes or there is something
like a dark shadow moving and then
that's where our attention goes and it's
automatic and the reason that we have
attention is to pay attention and then
summon all of our resources to either
take advantage of the opportunity or to
avoid the threat that's really the
purpose of attention so we sewn out
everything else we kind of blank
everything and just
focus on one thing that in that
particular moment is of highest value or
potentially the highest threat so
attention is a wonderful capacity you
know for instance little infants they
don't have attention they go all over
the place they look all over the place
and the brain eventually develops to pay
attention to things that again our
opportunity or a threat now we live in
such a complex environment that our
attention is hijacked all the time but
the antidote is not necessarily only
mindfulness you can get actually
obsessed with mindfulness and am i
paying attention so you're trying to pay
attention to paying attention and then
you're back to square one so I think
that to understand the value of
attention is number one and then to
recognize there are times where it's
perfectly okay when a car comes rushing
at you that's where you want your
attention you know or when you're really
giving a public speech that's where you
want your attention it's not always
right to say I'm mindful and mindful and
mindful you know the brain works over
time to monitor whether you're mindful
or not and the way that that I think is
the perfect way out of it is to pay
attention to your body sensation because
your body sensations will always signal
if there is something that's a potential
threat or a potential benefit and to
just pay attention to the body
sensations it relaxes it but you know by
all means for a few hours so you don't
pay attention to paying attention that's
perfectly fine you know it's I think
that we don't want to add more
difficulty of complexity to our lives I
think that that to to come more at ease
with the the wandering attention and
even observing as the intention is
attracted here or there or that I think
it's all part and parcel of being at
home with with this shifting influences
that that we perceive every day
you